on va donc en parler du ras-le-bol du
monde enseignant avec cette grève à
venir on en parle avec vous dans cette
seconde partie et nous a rejoint donc
sur ce plateau en direct
najat belkacem un co président de la
fcpe premier syndicat des parents d
élèves merci nous rejoindre à jacques
bel hassen ben emmanuel macron qui
comprend donc la lassitude vous vous
sentez compris vous en ce moment les
parents d'élèves
je m'étais évidemment que nous on ne se
sent pas compris sinon on n'aurait pas
appelé à soutenir ce mouvement
national jeudi bien évidemment ce que ce
que l'on comprend on ne comprend pas si
on combine nous notre intérêt c'est bien
évidemment que les écoles restent
ouvertes on est des parents avant tout
nous sommes pas un syndicat nous sommes
une association de parents donc on
représente des usagers de l'école donc
ce que ce qui nous intéresse surtout
c'est que il les moyens soient mises en
place dans les écoles pour justement
garantir que ces écoles restent ouvertes
or aujourd'hui on le voit bien il ya des
casse-tête de protocole qui se met en
place il y en a ce matin j'écoutais il y
en a 49 qui sont mis depuis le début de
la pandémie quarante neuf protocoles qui
ont eu lieu à l'école depuis depuis le
début donc vous voyez bien que la des
casse tête ça n'arrête pas la semaine
dernière on a vécu ce que nous nous
appelons le summum des protocoles où les
familles se sont retrouvées à aller
devoir aller travailler revenir chercher
leur enfant allait les faire tester
faire 1h30 t2 de queue pour aller pour
pouvoir tester leurs enfants les ramener
à l'école selon droit d'avoir une grille
des enseignants absents
repartir après avoir des autotests kiné
qui n'était pas dans les pharmacies
enfin voilà tout ça a fait que
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on en a un peu
marre et la situation on a vécu pendant
un an et demi deux ans aujourd'hui on a
joué le jeu on a joué le jeu de la de
l'école à la maison on a joué le jeu les
balles et les adolescents sont vaccinés
en majorité aujourd'hui on en a un que
oui ras-le-bol alors avant de faire nos
invités on va écouter jean castex 1 sur
ce casse tête justement sans mauvais jeu
de mots le premier ministre l'assemblée
nationale cet après midi
si comme vous nous le suggérer
nous n'avions pas rouvert les écoles
lundi dernier ce qu était une grave
erreur
pensez vous qu avec 90 villes cas par
jour on l'aurait rouverte lundi à nos
quinquas et tout ceci se serait
prolongée au détriment des enfants de
france
la priorité de la france en particulier
dans le secteur éducatif sous l'égide et
l'engagement du ministre de l'éducation
nationale c'est le plus possible de
laisser les écoles ouvertes car rien
n'est plus dramatique à court et à long
terme
à court et à long terme que de fermer
nos écoles nous revendiquons ce choix
najat belkacem qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez oui on a gardé les écoles
ouvertes ans est vrai que la france a
plutôt mieux réussies ou sur ce point
que beaucoup de pays mais enfin ça vous
console où vous trouvez que finalement
c'est pire
qu'à écouter chez nous on se positionne
pas si vous voulez sur sur l'ouverture
des écoles je vous ai dit notre position
est très claire notre intérêt c'est que
nos enfants aillent suivre une scolarité
donc là-dessus il n'y a pas de et pas de
doute possible auprès des parents là où
on se on se pose sérieusement des
questions c'est ok laisser les écoles
ouvertes coûte que coûte comme dirait le
président mais alors avec quels moyens
parce que aujourd'hui la réalité c'est
que pendant un an et demi on a vécu
cette pandémie et que la semaine
dernière un énième protocole arrivent
par voie de presse sans moyens parce que
les parents quand ils se sont retrouvés
devant les pharmacies il n'y avait pas
d'auto tests disponibles alors que le
protocole vous mais qu'on conteste les
enfants deux fois par auto test dans la
semaine donc aujourd'hui on ne comprend
plus pourquoi
l'exécutif ne met pas les moyens à
l'école pour protéger nos enfants
protégés sombre son personnel et donc en
installant des capteurs de co2 en
mettant des purificateurs d'air en
mettant des lave-mains éphémère aussi
pour les petits parce qu'on sait que les
petits les gestes bas hier sont
essentiels tous ces moyens que nous nous
réclamons depuis quasiment le début de
la pandémie rien quasiment n'est pas par
an dans les écoles actuellement donc
aujourd'hui on se pose cette question là
nos enfants ils ont quand même aussi
vécu pendant un an et demi la la
pandémie avec dédé des problèmes
structurels qui était déjà existantes
qui se sont amplifiés notamment le
remplacement des professeurs savez je je
je discutais avec une maman pas plus
tard que fin de semaine dernière qui
elle a pris un nouveau travail est la
seule peur qu'elle avait c'était de
devoir récupérer ses enfants parce
qu'elle est en période de préavis et
qu'elle a déjà donné beaucoup de jours
par rapport à ces problématiques d'école
voyez la peur des français elle est là
en fait notamment part non évidemment
c'est il va aller travailler il veut
laisser des deux écoles ouvertes mais
ils veulent qu'on leur donne les moyens
que ça que ce soit fut réellement france
quoi travaille quand vous entendez cette
maman c'est vrai que les parents sont
confrontés à des situations ubuesques
carton comme les directeurs et les
enseignants on se dit parfois le
gouvernement est un peu hors sol vous
comprenez c'est à cette colère
honnêtement
ma barbe blanche je te promènes père de
famille et pas ailleurs j'en sais il ya
en université depuis plus de trente ans
et j'ai des étudiants qui
malheureusement pour beaucoup ne sont
pas très en forme en ce moment je vous
rappelle simplement une chose l'om est
ce nous dit que dans deux mois la moitié
de la population européenne sera
contaminée par le coronavirus alors je
comprends en fait tout le monde est
crevé permettez moi cette familiarité
tous crever plus personne n'en peux plus
je le sais évidemment nous le savons
tous que nous sommes crever le problème
c'est comment fait-on pour résoudre tout
cela quand les enseignants sont sont
malades et comment fait-on pour les
remplacer par qui les remplaceront ne
peut pas mettre n'importe qui pour
garder nos enfants donc si vous voulez
le gouvernement parent au plus pressé
madame a raison quand on dit à quelqu'un
fait une heure et demie de queue devant
une pharmacie est tellement perdre une
journée de travail dans le gouvernement
essaie de s'adapter pour supprimer cette
heure et demie que on pare au plus
pressé dans une situation d'urgence
ne sera jamais satisfaisant est ce qu'on
espère c'est tenir les 2/3 juste les
mois qui restent jusqu'à l'été et puisse
aller mieux mais on se rend bien compte
que former des personnes pour garder nos
enfants ça demande beaucoup plus de
temps qu'on en a actuellement on ne peut
pas confier nos enfants portent eux qui
est madame à réseau il faut laisser on
ne va pas non plus confié nos enfants
aux grands parents ils vont attraper les
coronavirus et finir au cimetière facile
vous voulez il faut être clair et
concret n'est en réalité et s'adapter au
jour le jour et c'est ce que le
gouvernement essaie de faire avec des
échecs oui je le reconnais mais bien
malin que je serai vieux
monsieur je vous proposais une carte
chez nous parce que là ça fait comme
plusieurs échecs que vous reconnaissez
du gouvernement et j'en suis quand même
ravi de cette lucidité une chose
la seule chose qu'il n'avait pas loupé
c'était l'école il avait loupé les
masques il avait loupé les tests on
avait été en retard sur les vaccins la
seule chose qu'il n'avait pas loupé ils
n'ont vous paie et on aura fait le tour
de cette pandémie dans une ambiance
d'impréparation
d'amateurisme on avait suggéré notamment
avec valérie pécresse de faire en sorte
de repousser d'une semaine pour éviter
cela puisque toute façon on va être
clair avec la grève de jeudi est le fait
que bas le vendredi vous allez voir que
ça va être un peu pareil et qu'on aura
perdu énormément de temps et que des
gens auront perdu potentiellement leur
capacité à aller au boulot et c'est la
semaine on l'aura perdu ça nous aura
coûté de l'énervement de l'argent et de
l'impréparation et quelque chose c'est
bien sûr se révèle regarder cette
semaine si on avait mis en place assez
rapidement le décalage ça aurait permis
d'éviter ces couacs la sort est permis
par exemple de bosser avec madame qui
est notre intervenante de bosser avec
les associations de parents d'élèves
cela j'ai eu la chance de travailler à
l'époque pour un ministre de l'éducation
qui s'appelle luc chatel je sais combien
c'est important de discuter avec les
associations de parents d'élèves avec
les syndicats et peut-être que si on
avait eu un exercice moins solitaire du
pouvoir un exercice qui soit -
autarcique du pouvoir on aurait
simplement convié ces associations pour
discuter avec elle effectivement vous
l'aurez appris par voie de presse et
vous aurait été peut-être embarqué dans
cette décision et vous auriez fait
corriger potentiellement à ce
gouvernement qui n'entend rien un
certain nombre de mesures et on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec le fait que ça
aura été réussi le gouvernement aura
loupé sur tous les tableaux alors bien
évidemment quand il s'agit d'envoyer des
chèques aux uns et aux autres c'est plus
facile de le faire et dans ce cas les
gens vous dire ah bah finalement moi mon
secteur a été épargné parce que j'ai
reçu un petit chèque mais ça s'appelle
pas une gestion s'appelle acheter des
voix et donc la préparation et
l'amateurisme on aura fait le tour on
aura fait deux ans dans lequel toutes
les cases auront été cochée ils se
seront louper najat belkacem le mot de
la fin pour vous un jean michel blanquer
requis qui disait ce matin chez nos
confrères de bfm on ne fait pas grève
contre un virus qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez parce qu'elle part mettre des
purificateurs d'air qu est-ce qu
aujourd'hui on a du mal à le comprendre
demande les enseignants et les parents
d'élèves pour solutionner cette cette
situation compliquée effectivement
écoutez moi je me prononce son nom des
parents d'élèves je ne suis pas voilà je
ne suis pas enseignante voilà je
travaille par ailleurs donc je suis
bénévole dans cette association ça fait
un an et demi deux ans qu'on vit cette
grecs ont vis est ce virus donc
aujourd'hui qu'on vienne pas nous dire
qu'on combat un virus on sait on sait
depuis un an et demi là ce que nous nous
reprochons exactement à l'exécutif c'est
la mise en place de moyens ou le respect
des gestes barrière vous l'avez citer
les capteurs on nous renvoie aux
collectivités les collectivités nous
renvoie à l'état donc nous on se
retrouve entre les deux le les
purificateurs d'air on a des fenêtres
qui n'ouvrait pas dans les classes ça
c'est une réalité c'est très
terre-à-terre les tests salivaires des
tests salivaires je suis désolé mais
vous êtes vous avez dit bon exactement
vous êtes tous quasiment par an vous
savez que des tests avec le goupillon
dans le nez pour trois fois par semaine
on sait très bien que les adultes auront
du mal à le supporter alors je vous je
vous raconte même pas pour les enfants
donc les tests salivaires où sont ils
pour les plus petits tout ça et puis et
pointent aussi de test aux abords des
écoles on en a discuté avec monsieur
blanc caire la semaine dernière nous
étions en réunion avec lui nous lui
avons dit la semaine dernière à
installer des points de test aux abords
des écoles vous voyez bien que ça ne
marche pas le système de monde et si tôt
à la dernière minute on met en place
sans moyens ça ne marche pas donc
faisons en sorte aujourd'hui d'un effet
laisser les écoles ouvertes mais avec
des moyens supplémentaires mon matériel
et humain
merci beaucoup à jabel à sa merci
également à jonas raddad sur ce plateau
france quattro boeuf merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir